i don't want to see anything with andrew
tate this lisp having [ __ ] right and
mind you i think a lot of people who
watch andrew tate they do it ironically
and
that's what sometimes people forget
there are these in-cell guys that watch
him that really believe in his idea of
what a real man is alpha true alpha male
1 next to a swimming pool is [ __ ]
flinging around nunchucks like a virgin
and a cigar yeah yeah this is what a
real man looks like when i saw a video
of this you know swinging around
nunchucks i was like you shut the [ __ ]
up yeah in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another early ass
morning
they don't know that though
i'm letting you know so you look at the
bags under my eyes
i was telling dave it felt like a work
commute coming over here uh i was
telling david it felt like a work
commute coming over here
we haven't i
never shoot podcasts this early but
we're in the new studio space and
there's time slots that we have to fill
in so you know what we're [ __ ] here
early man it's what we do
it's been a crazy
crazy time out in the celebrity world
as it always is bro every time i hear
this when i heard about this news at
first right
if you guys don't know who ann haight is
um
you're probably a normal person i feel
like a lot of people don't know who
anthony is she's the type of actress
where if you see her you recognize her
but you might not know her name yeah she
was a uh i just remember watching her in
like daytime soap operas because when i
was a kid i wouldn't have cable yeah so
whenever i didn't go to school which was
pretty often
okay i could like so my parents would go
to work at around uh 8 a.m right and i
think so i would leave to school earlier
and then i would pretend like i'm
walking to school and i just chill
somewhere go like a del taco or whatever
what not ditch in school and i would
just wait them out and then i would walk
right back home yeah and then i would
turn on daytime tv and sometimes
there'll be soap operas i never told the
friends i watched soap operas but i did
and ann hayes was a really popular soap
opera actually so that's the only reason
why i know her she's also in a couple of
films but i don't remember oh yeah she
was in some pretty big films um i think
she was in uh with al pacino and uh
johnny depp and uh donnie brasco oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh it was johnny's wife
in the movie
and then she was also in it with de niro
and um
i can't remember i can't remember the
movie nate but she's been you know she
shared the screen with some pretty big
heavy hitters and hey she always looked
like somebody that could have been
somebody's like
racist housewife or something
like
she was like
she could be honest well i mean on the
farm and she would be listening to ellen
degeneres for a bit i think during like
the early 2000s dude so
i didn't know that anne hage was gay
well so that was the thing that was her
only gay relationship after
oh really she just went to guys i mean i
guess she's bi but that was their only
public gay relationship
and yeah when what because so before we
talk about what actually happened to
anne h which by the time this comes out
it's been on it for a while yeah but i
don't really care
because this is fascinating so when i
was you know googling and looking this
up
i was looking about what happened with
this crazy car accident or this crazy
incident so all i googled was anne hayes
crazy incident right yeah and it wasn't
the thing that happened recently that
popped up it was the thing with ellen
degeneres when they broke up
so they had something crazy too where
she had like a psychotic episode she was
like on uh i forgot what type of she was
on ecstasy or some [ __ ] like that
um and i think uh ellen degeneres had to
put a restraining order on her support
really i didn't know about it
yeah it was some craz robin can you look
that up
before i get [ __ ] shot on
sorry restraining order again it was
look up ellen degeneres and uh
ellen degeneres and robin couch
immediately
[Laughter]
yeah so they
so apparently she's had a few other like
psychotic breakdowns so
when i first read about the the car
accident that happened right so she
basically ran her car yeah into another
house
yeah yeah so basically prior to that she
had ran into a garage and she almost hit
a pedestrian and then after that she hit
another car and then she went into
so it wasn't just an isolated yeah
exactly it wasn't just an isolated
situation there was things leading up to
and you know she showed behaviors of
a little concern prior to that happening
like she bought a bright red wig um and
then like she was pictured that day
earlier in that day with that red wig in
the car along with a bottle that had a
red top which probably was liquor so
people were kind of guessing that she
might have been driving under the
influence which it turned out blood uh
blood reports i think found out that
there was no alcohol in her blood but
she did have
coke with some traces of fentanyl in her
blood so she was still she was awesome
she was still on something so she has a
podcast apparently and apparently oh
really yeah and so people were saying
that on the same day or it was reported
that on the same day that she released
her podcast which she possibly recorded
that podcast the same day she was
talking about how she's like depressed
and whatever whatnot oh yeah and that
she was like drunk off a vodka and
chased it with like wine so her
publicist came out and said that was
pre-recorded okay but you know there's
no way to actually confirm right that's
what publicists do they're going to do
damage control so it's like listen she
wasn't drinking but there was fentanyl
he said coke and fentanyl get it correct
it wasn't alcohol okay
it was not impaired by alcohol dude
that's just so nuts because only
recently too and i talked about on the
other podcast where there was the girl
in la the nurse oh yeah nicole linton
yeah that
she was on some crazy [ __ ] too she went
90 and a 35 bro she went 90 miles per
hour in a 35 zone killed five people and
an unborn baby one of those five people
was also a child right a family that's
[ __ ] crazy yo check this [ __ ] out
there was a woman at a gas station when
this accident happened she said she was
at the gas station
as this thing happened
a child's body flew and landed in front
of her
because it was ejected out of the car
bro like how gruesome is that how
[ __ ] horrific and traumatic is that
bro and they tried to resuscitate the
child but the child was already dead at
that point so
yeah nicole linton she was um she was a
nurse and apparently people were saying
that she um
there was
she has a history oh yeah behaving like
this yeah this isn't like a one-off she
had like i think 14 accidents prior to
this one like she's
actually so both of them that you know
what ties them together is obviously
mental health issues right both of them
definitely have a history of mental
health issues with um anhesh she was
abused by her her father um and i guess
that kind of led to her mental
instability and mental issues with um
nicole linton i'm not exactly sure what
her background is but this incident what
caused her to speed down the street like
that was she got into a fight with her
boyfriend so clearly you know no normal
person does that right you get into a
fight with your your spouse or your your
partner whatever you get heated yeah
you'll get a doughnut you're not [ __ ]
running 90 miles per hour in a 35 and
then running a red light at that that's
why she [ __ ] smashed into those cars
you know what's so crazy about that too
is just like every time something like
this happens the person who's driving
always survives
she got away with like scratches and
minor injuries always survive and they
kill everybody else i know man i know
but i mean she's going away for a long
time you know and and look man all this
isn't to excuse what they did but there
is there is a caveat there which is that
you know bring the whole mental health
issue to the forefront right yeah with
with both people in this with anhesh and
this nicole linton right so
that's kind of like sparking that that
conversation again but you know still
what they did was crazy that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] nuts did you find that thing
robin
i couldn't find any info i wrote it
right there oh all right but anyways so
frustrating
this is why we have robin couch because
i just be saying some salacious [ __ ]
has a closed vagina
did you guys hear about this [ __ ]
well it is also incredibly difficult to
get a restraining order so if somebody
has one you know that they really felt
like they needed it so maybe it was like
rumors of going to get one and she just
didn't go through it so what was the
thing about them was it they just had a
bad breakup
all i could find was a quote after they
broke up of ellen saying we're not in
touch but i don't want anybody to feel
hurt like i'm not really gonna comment
on it we're not talking oh so she
punched her in the mouth
well i mean that and they could have
done maybe at some point there were
there was more information regarding
their relationship and the aftermath of
it but maybe it was just damage control
with that too yeah he arguably clearly
remembers something about ecstasy all
right i'm not [ __ ] crazy
you're trying to read the facts
on ecstasy you know what i did the other
day that was so [ __ ] embarrassing bro
[ __ ] i don't even know why i'm saying
this have you accidentally texted
somebody uh something that you're
supposed to somebody else i have yes now
i so yeah
there's this little uh group chat that i
have with a couple of friends yeah
well we'll send like either funny [ __ ]
or fat asses that's this is what we do
right white fat asses
my brain's wired okay right and you know
it's really nothing it usually is it's
all jokes and [ __ ]
but a buddy of mine sent me
this [ __ ] this person i don't know who
this person is right but obviously i
have like a blue check mark on my on my
[ __ ] or whatever whatnot yeah
and so most likely if i dm somebody
they'll respond back especially because
they want cloud or whatever yeah but oh
this is through instagram this is the
instagram it's like a stupid little
thing most of the times it's jokes every
now and then it's like a fat ass or
something like that which
yeah whatever that's what guys do and so
they said that
and there was this girl like dancing or
whatever what not right i wrote some
kind of stupid comment i was like i
wanna i was like i want to suffocate and
bury myself in that ass oh that's what i
said as a joke right yeah yeah
you know when you when you're with a
group of guys you kind of just follow
their legal as jokes and they were
laughing because that's not normally how
i was talking so i was just you know
writing some stupid [ __ ] like that but
it turns out i didn't know i don't know
how it happened this way but apparently
i clicked on her profile and i sent a
comment
[Laughter]
the reason why this happened is because
i couldn't go to sleep and i smoked that
night that was [ __ ] delirious oh my
god which is why that joke was so funny
they were cracking the [ __ ] up yeah
and the next day
this person who i don't know
dm's me and i'm like oh what is this
yeah and then they just wrote lol you're
so funny and i'm like so funny the [ __ ]
i don't know who you are yeah so i just
kind of ignored it went on and then
i went back to the message
and i looked and i was like there's
something that i wrote i [ __ ] wrote
that [ __ ] to her
and my [ __ ] heart started beating so
[ __ ] fast
i was like yo i don't what the [ __ ]
i [ __ ] wanted to die yeah because i
don't talk to women yeah you know what i
mean
but thank god that i'm a comic because
she took it but i was about to say
that's that's your saving grace right
there thank you god
she was just laughing you know and then
we chopped it up a little bit whatever
and then move the [ __ ] on but you're
probably listening to this right now and
yes
we had that group chat and we saw your
ass and i said i wanted to bury my face
in there well it doesn't even matter
because you told her directly so you
don't even need to say it was never
trying to play it off but that wasn't
you have a very nice butt and
well was she somebody with like a pretty
decent following decent follow-up okay
she's an influencer very very sweet
person yeah great personality okay
bigger than her ass
god damn it dude you want to bury your
face into personalities what you meant
to say i wanted i wanted to die
i wanted to [ __ ] die dude that was
speaking of toxic masculinity
that's me appreciating the beautiful
woman form yeah i mean you know you just
you're just complimenting her i guess on
her assets
yes it just i
i just joke like that that's how i joke
all right
you know who else has a big robin ass
robin couch
is this the statement of fact yes robert
are you single
yep robin is
for aldi robin is single yeah all right
she is
super smart
all right she's also an aspiring
thespian all right and else you have a
fat ass there you go somebody was half
listening they may have thought you
called me an aspiring lesbian
[Laughter]
and i am unfortunately heterosexual okay
so apparently all the all the single men
out there
those
what else do you need you know i know
doc so it was kind of crazy like going
back to like the anne hayes thing right
yeah
it's weird too because i got into a
little bit of an argument
argument with regarding it it was just
me and muriel oh okay you know every
time this is the normal talk yeah
he knows we bicker all the time
because that's just how he speaks to
each other
you'll see it on the podcast
but
we got into a little bit of a back and
forth because whenever it comes to the
subject of like pop stars or
specifically bts do she gets riled the
[ __ ] up oh bro right you got to
understand the bts army well k-pop fans
in general are pretty hardcore but
especially bts bro i have a cousin who's
like
she's
she's like an older sister to me now
she's i think in her
oh man i won't say like her 50s or
whatever she's been a bts fan since like
the beginning days right so she feels
this like
hardcore i'm a real fan like these i i
saw them come up from nothing and i
supported them so when anybody says
something kind of negative she feels
kind of like don't you dare
wait this is your cousin yeah how long
should you be a loser
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding but
i've talked about fandom in general why
i'm not why i don't like it not not
k-pop fan just just hardcore yeah in
general right right because you know
it can be toxic man is it very toxic and
it becomes something personal that
really shouldn't be
specifically with with music and
everything else because it's art is
highly subjective yeah so
any like for example if i if i said oh
man i hate arrowhead you go
this [ __ ]
you're trying
words right now you know what arrowhead
has done for me it hydrates me it keeps
me alive the [ __ ] how dare is this it's
just odds you don't know what they've
done for me yeah i don't and also i
don't [ __ ] care yeah exactly i don't
[ __ ] care what they did for you this
is a conversation you asked me if i like
if i like their music or not yeah and i
gave you an answer see that's i hate
when that happens when they when they're
asking you a question but they're kind
of framing it in a way of like you
better agree with me
or else you know you're gonna catch this
this [ __ ] you know i'm gonna go on
this rant about why you should agree
with me yeah yeah it's just this odd
thing it's like don't ask if you like
don't ask if you're only expecting an
answer that you wanted and it's a very
very obnoxious habit that people have
right yes because look and i only say it
because when i was younger i used to do
that a lot too but when you're [ __ ] i
don't know in your [ __ ] thirties and
you're doing it i'm not saying this is
marital yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah completely just in
general yeah
like it's just a really weird way to
have conversations with people i
disagree with people all the time yeah
and
99 of the time it's not gonna get to
that point it shouldn't it shouldn't
it's okay to disagree it's okay to have
your own opinion man yeah but the
problem is is when people feel a certain
type of way about it and they involve
like you know their feelings about it
rather than just having a mature adult
conversation about it and then if you
guys disagree and and then
figure out why it is that you guys
disagree then you guys can agree to
disagree and just partner with facebook
right it's what it is man like i've
cause the the topic that became uh uh
not an issue but between me apparently
she was getting super like riled up yeah
was because we i was talking to her
about how a lot of these k-pop bands are
they're manufactured absolutely 100
and when they when they're younger
they're in these like little boy band
groups and they're pushing them out like
factory kids and eventually
what happens as they get older they gain
their popularity they're gonna seek
their individuality out right because
they can now yeah they have a name they
have this huge fandom whenever their
contract ends or whatever it is they
will figure out a way that hey maybe you
know what i don't like some people in
this group
well that's the problem a lot of times
they're locked up into like 20 25-year
contracts you know so it's like i don't
want to be a part of this they have to
buy out their contracts or some other
[ __ ] right
and i was kind of talking to her about
this stuff and we've seen this multiple
times in korean groups right we've seen
these bands split up because there's a
lot of stuff behind the scenes that you
don't really know about you don't know
who these people are so for so just to
wrap it back to people like anne haish
and all this other stuff you never know
who these people are you will never
never ever know all you all you people
out there who are super hardcore fans of
anybody you know
take the entertainment for what it is
you can't judge these people for who
they are because you don't know their
[ __ ] personal lives you don't know if
they're scumbags one of the greatest
things ever not greatest i'm sorry but
one of the most enlightening things that
proved this point was was the
was it
dbsk
where one of them oh no it was big bang
they had a [ __ ]
what do you call it
yeah well he had the [ __ ] whole
prostitution ring going on yeah yeah
yeah the whole pr prostitution i believe
there might have been human trafficking
involved in that too yeah and it's like
and people are like oh my god i thought
he was a good person why yeah based on
what based on what based on pr because
that's exactly what they're saying the
game shows that they do yeah
like what is this well that and and
we've we've we've kind of touched up on
this throughout the years you know over
over the podcast about kind of the whole
k-pop industry and i have a little more
extra insight than the average person
because i used to you know do work for
that right
but yeah it's what you're saying is
completely true man people don't really
know anything about what's going on
behind the scenes and i'm not gonna name
anybody specific or call out any labels
right because yeah that's their business
but i will say a lot of these
cookie cutter very clean looking artists
right they're doing drugs yeah you know
they're [ __ ] they're they're agencies
and their pr people will say oh no they
don't ever date they don't ever drink
they don't ever smoke nah man that's to
keep that pristine image that they
created for them and then that that
whole industry right because that let's
be honest man the k-pop industry is
about keeping it really pg pg-13 if
they're getting a little you know
ambitious right i'm the nicest kind of
sweetest person in the world you have
have you ever met anybody like that that
has stuck to that [ __ ] narrative for
their whole life and you have to
understand too they are now celebrities
at the highest level these are grown ass
[ __ ] men with [ __ ] dicks and balls
exactly with women throwing themselves
at them right and look
this is not an attack on k-pop if you
like k-pop that's fine with me you know
i think some k-pop music is very catchy
too not exactly my cup of tea but i'll
i'll say just from an objective
standpoint i could see why it's so
catchy but
just treat it as entertainment yeah
don't don't believe for a second that
you actually know who these people are
and what's going on behind the scenes
with them they like that's what i'm
saying when it comes to the whole bts
thing or just any any korean pop person
that's hot at the moment right people
defend them as if they know them
personally i know they did this stuff
for me no they didn't do it for you
personally they had a producer from
america and a writer in korea that made
this song they didn't by the way too
just to burst your [ __ ] bubble you
know when these artists say they oh i
wrote this they didn't write it yeah
most of most of the artists out there
don't write their songs yeah you know
and i'm not saying this is a bad thing
what i'm saying is when it gets to a
point where some when you ask somebody
an opinion about a band that you like
and you say they don't like it and then
you get mad at them don't start that
conversation if it's like if look if the
conversation's like hey their song is
catchy they dance well good like them
yeah good choreography their music
videos i mean great like that's cool
you know you get something out of the
entertainment value from that but then
if you say this person is so pure and
you don't know [ __ ] about them yeah and
that's facts it's not an opinion you
really don't know who they are as a
person look we're not going to name
names either but there was uh uh k-pop
so back in the day um at this time you
know when i was doing youtube there
wasn't that many that asian
representation thing and the k-pop wave
was just starting uh
there was a boy group at the time that
was really popular but they split a
couple of them started doing solo [ __ ]
well two of them came to k-town and they
were doing this thing and their
promotion company hit up a bunch of
other youtubers at the time and i was
one of them because i was one of the few
korean people that were you know
influencers yeah so i went out and this
one of these guys dude this guy was a
[ __ ] scumbag man and i'm talking
about you know
the image that they put out on these
variety shows they're super quiet and
small because you know that's very
attractive for the korean audience from
people and like oh my god this guy's so
popular but he's so humble this [ __ ]
scumbag was out in um what was that spot
that we used to go to the upstairs spot
in cape town come come here
yeah just [ __ ] grabbing women like
grabbing them like physically grabbing
wow he busted into donald trump yeah and
then you know you know i used to be like
really short-tempered [ __ ] like that but
so literally i'd like grab them like yo
you can't do that here or anywhere else
like don't do that [ __ ] especially
because one of the girls he grabbed was
somebody that i knew and you know it's a
weird position for me to be in because
number one i'm getting paid for this
right but number two i don't care
you know
but the guy kind of walked around as if
he owned [ __ ] like he's like the [ __ ]
girl he's going around [ __ ]
physically grabbing women and i was like
bro you can't do that he's oh i'm just
having a good time i was like don't
[ __ ] grab my friend that ain't a good
time bro that's the lawsuit exactly you
know and so whatever what not and then
whoever the [ __ ] he's with is
apologizing and says i'm gonna [ __ ]
don't apologize like don't [ __ ] grab
these like it's really simple right
don't [ __ ] touch people
yeah and obviously some of the girls
that he was grabbing they enjoyed it
because they knew who he was
but
which i still don't find acceptable
which is really fun it doesn't change
the fact it doesn't change the fact yeah
but when he grabbed my friend and she
was like doing this and he [ __ ]
reached out for her again when i grabbed
his arm i was like hey what the [ __ ] are
you doing i wasn't you know bigging up
on him yeah yeah because obviously what
i'm gonna do [ __ ]
no no no no no no
after you give him the dave slap yeah i
mean because we were super cordial yeah
you know up until that point but the
moment he had uh a little bit of alcohol
and maybe some other [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
knows because when they're in the states
they're trying to party they don't have
those [ __ ] drug restrictions like
they do it out in korea so they're
[ __ ] parting their ass off i'm not
saying this is what bts is
yeah don't just give me an example of
right how we don't know
more than meets the eye right
so it was just like that that idea of
like not knowing what these celebrities
uh go through on the daily or you don't
even know who these people are so
whenever like news comes out about
celebrities they go i can't believe it
why can't you believe it yeah
why can't you believe it at all and you
know they always say too fame only
heightens who you really are as a person
like if you were an [ __ ] before
you're going to be a bigger [ __ ] now
now that everybody loves you because you
can get away with just about anything so
when i talk [ __ ] about sima loot i'm
kidding i'm kidding
you can get into that again
because this is my bit now yeah i know
it
has turned into a bit of a bit i know no
but yeah and and we've also touched up
on that subject about fame too in the
past but yeah not every human being can
handle it man yeah it's hard it's not
normal it's not it's not it's not a
normal way to live and be treated at all
especially when you reach the heights of
fame where you become kind of a
household name and internationally
recognized right like
dude the world is pretty much handed to
you on a silver platter and god forbid
man you start this at a young age before
you even become an adult
it's gonna warp your world view in a way
that's
probably gonna be hard to to
change how often have you seen young
stars end up and you know i'm using this
word normal
in just like the traditional way but
somebody who's mentally stable yeah uh
really rare really rare really rare
right like look at all the smith kids
these weird ass [ __ ] you know i
mean hey they might be cool but they
live in their own world oh for sure you
know for sure they might be really cool
but they definitely live in their own
world like i remember watching this
interview with jaden smith and the
reporter was asking him about friends
and he was like and by the way this kid
was probably had to be i mean you have
to double check you guys could look up
this footage i don't care to be correct
about this but he was maybe in his early
teens or maybe even younger and he was
talking about oh man like i don't like
kicking it with kids i like kicking with
adults because you know these kids are
all over the place they're just super
excitable they don't know how to focus
i'm like
you're a dweeb and i'm gonna take your
[ __ ] lunch money
like the idea that somebody that age is
looking down at his peers who are in
similar age saying that he's better than
them is obviously something that it was
just learned yeah but
that's just an odd thing in general and
you can kind of see this with all these
like younger celebrities
and you know sometimes people like to
relegate it to oh they're just at a
higher level of thinking or they're just
[ __ ] weird how come we can't just say
that now they're just being a little
[ __ ] we're just there look man i
don't think it's far-fetched to say that
they're disconnected
from mainstream reality you know um and
as a result can be a little bit
delusional you know what i mean like
when you're
living a life with that much wealth that
much fame and that much power there's no
way that you're not going to get
disconnected from what's going on on the
day-to-day like an average person's life
even in even on a smaller scale not just
um
being a celebrity but there are people
that that um
that i associate with too
that work regular jobs but they make a
lot of like regular jobs meaning that
not in entertainment yeah
they make a lot of money now and even
that too growing up with how we grew up
where it wasn't a lot of money they've
forgotten what it's like to be the
person who makes less than 100k and the
way that they talk about things is
[ __ ] weird because now they're in
this upper like this two percent area
yeah and how they view the world is how
these two percent of you even though
they came from here yeah so for example
i had a conversation with a friend about
uh this was during pandemic and it was
covet and he was talking about oh i
don't know why people are tripping about
covey because you know we're staying at
home things are nice and i'm like hold
on a second bro you have a [ __ ] 4
million mansion so of course staying at
home for you means something very very
[ __ ] different so yeah when you're at
home and you're next to your basketball
court and your [ __ ] pool yeah yeah
quarantine is [ __ ] dope yeah it's not
that much seven figures in your bank
account but you're not really accounting
for the fact that there are people right
now who don't have what you have a
studio apartment with four kids yeah
exactly and they gotta stay in that tiny
little home with these people and
they're losing their mind and they're
going [ __ ] crazy so just hearing him
say that i had to tell him like yo i'm
my bad [ __ ] millionaire yeah like do
you do you not remember when you were in
a [ __ ] duplex and you i was like
imagine you when you're in the duplex
with three of your siblings with your
mom yeah
and you had to stay in that place for
[ __ ] a month without no without
knowing when you're gonna be able to you
know do things again exactly would you
have been sane would you have lost your
[ __ ] mind because the topic came up
where at the time during pandemic there
was a lot of domestic violence that was
coming up and all this other [ __ ] yeah
and he couldn't [ __ ] wrap his head
around he goes you're staying at home
why can't you just chill yeah why don't
you just relax yeah it's like cause i
can't [ __ ] relax bro i'm just
shoulder shoulder with me
it's dark in here my parents will turn
on the lights
but it's weird though like when people
reset a certain level of fame or wealth
they kind of forget where they come from
they lose that perspective yeah and all
he could see was oh i'm i'm chilling at
home what's the problem
what are you talking about that becomes
their new reality right and little by
little they they dive into that
newer lifestyle of theirs and yeah as a
result you just start to kind of forget
what it was like to struggle what it was
like to be inconvenienced by these
things because that's not your norm
anymore far from it right that's like
something that's in in
way back in your mind that maybe can
brought to the surface when yeah you
give them a reminder like hey man it
wasn't like that you know when when you
were in this situation don't did you
forget that hey man i have a little bit
of that too dude sometimes i go back
home to sacramento and i go back to the
spots i used to kick it at because
that's where i used to eat and i see
these [ __ ] hoodlums outside i'm like
look at you pieces of [ __ ]
not going to school you [ __ ] losers
well i think i never went to school
i was that piece of [ __ ] exactly i get
scared sometimes when i go back to the
places i used to kick it at yeah oh my
god i used to be here this is dangerous
my dad told me a pretty funny story um
recently actually uh that a couple
nights ago um and it was there's the
7-eleven um
around like the neighborhood where it
was bad and a lot of like gangs and [ __ ]
used to roll through there and i guess
like he called me one night um and this
is around the time when like cell phones
had just come out yeah and he's like hey
uh it's you know it's late where you at
and i was like oh i'm just chilling at 7
11 right now
he's like it's late it's dangerous there
like why are you hanging out at a place
like that and apparently i told them
like pops
anybody that there is to worry about i
probably know them here
so
it's cool they're my people
and he said he was like what the [ __ ]
so kind of the same [ __ ] like now if i'm
going in an area like that seeing you
know
uh people a little rough around the
edges right i might feel like oh man
look at these look at these
troublemakers
i don't like that [ __ ] at all man yeah
speaking of like people who are rich or
super out of touch freaking um i was
telling you about this guy andrew tate
talk are you talking about toxic
masculinity dave he's actually in the
group chat
he wasn't the group chat
now i knew nothing about this guy for
the longest time
absolutely nothing
and
just recently on my youtube you know the
youtube shorts
i just keep seeing this [ __ ] bald
[ __ ]
popping up in my youtube shorts all the
time i was getting spammed with this
dude out of [ __ ] nowhere you know why
because the [ __ ] fat ass comment bro
no no no
come on man this algorithm always knows
bro algorithm doesn't know [ __ ] because
sending me ben shapiro and i [ __ ]
hate that guy
right so
i don't hate him he's just his voice
annoys the [ __ ] out yeah he does have a
pretty look okay these are the facts
i sort of got if he keeps talking about
him as a man a woman's a woman and the
reason why
all right so joe
when you come up here and you talk about
this podium we're talking about the
minimum wage we're like dude i don't
know what you're saying slow the [ __ ]
down yeah the reason why i also dislike
the way that he speaks because he's
trying to cram all this [ __ ]
information into this it's like 10
seconds it's like you could you could
just slow down yeah and especially if
you're in a debate format allow somebody
to i don't know well that's exactly like
a tactic though right is is to [ __ ]
get them like walking backwards and get
them on their heel and yeah i mean so
you know that's that's i think that's
his background as he comes from like
probably he was on the debate team or
some [ __ ] and yeah yeah so
uh so andrew tate just like ben shapiro
was just popping up on my thing and i
would always say don't recommend this
channel don't and i'm trying to get that
algorithm to understand i don't want to
see anything with andrew tate this lisp
having [ __ ] right and mind you i think a
lot of people who watch andrew tate they
do it ironically and
that's what sometimes people forget
there are these in-cell guys that watch
him that really believe in his idea of
what a real man is alpha true alpha male
1 next to a swimming pool is [ __ ]
flinging around nunchucks like a virgin
and a cigar yeah yeah this is what a
real man looks like when i saw a video
of this whole you know swinging around
nunchucks i was like you shut the [ __ ]
up yeah you say nothing be quiet yeah
so
he just pops up everywhere right and so
what i found out is that he has this uh
pyramid scheme right so basically you
follow this program about hustlers
university another virgin ass thing to
call your [ __ ]
so he has hustlers university you have
this whole discord or whatever and
basically it's a pyramid scheme thing
too where
apparently like if you share it with
somebody blah blah somebody gets a sign
with your code and what you do and
and the methodology that they teach you
how to do it with is to take clips of
his stuff and just post it so he is
literally everywhere because his minions
are doing the work so you cannot help
but see him yeah and he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about what he says he says whatever
the [ __ ] he wants and a part of me too
when he talks about the stuff and if you
guys want to look up clips of andrew
tate you'll just see him just kind of
defining what manhood is what woman what
womanhood is
and
it's like in the most extreme forms it's
like oh bro all the way over here yeah
yeah you know he's he's
he's definitely a misogynist i don't
think there's uh he doesn't deny it
either he thinks that being a misogynist
is a good thing and he says things like
you know he he prefers to sleep with you
know younger girls 18 year olds whatever
because he gets to leaving jesus christ
leave an imprint on them you know
sometimes i like them to stand there in
the corner i pee on them like a fire
hydrant yeah
um
so yeah this dude is definitely a
scumbag in all different ways
uh but you know i always
have a certain reservation talking about
dudes like this because it's like on one
end i feel like
yeah it does need to be talked about
because it needs to be somewhat
corrected i guess but on the other hand
it's like
ah we continue to feel that fire for him
even if we criticize him and talk
negatively about it
it's still speaking his name it's still
giving him a platform and that's what he
loves so this is why all these you know
we all know that all the social media
platforms are hyperliberal right he's
not gonna survive there so youtube
kicked him off he could no longer make
it he's completely banned from youtube
yeah he's banned from twitter he's also
banned from instagram too no and
instagram yeah and facebook everything
is now blocked so his main way of
getting through
yeah
because he's like
he's a major trumper oh i believe it
yeah i could definitely see that yeah so
he's been blocked from every social
media platform which i don't think has
happened to anybody besides like uh
what's his face uh
the the conspiracy dude alex jones
yeah alex jones has been banned from
[ __ ] everything yeah right
and so you know people have been talking
on the internet like oh this is this is
wrong because you're blocking free
speech so how why do you get to block
free speech when he's just you know
speaking quote unquote his truth and the
reason why i dislike first of all i hate
that phrase i'm speaking my truth that
is the biggest trash phrase i've ever
heard in my life every person that has
used the word i'm speaking my truth it
originally was supposed to be a very
good thing it was supposed to be people
saying like listen i'm just speaking
honestly and then it went from people
being like oh i'm right all the time
yeah because i'm speaking my truth yes
my truth is true so many of those
phrases and sayings have gotten so
warped over the years especially in like
the past five years um
i think
a lot of it kind of came from the trump
era right and and let's be honest the
trump era never went away we're still
i'm not i'm not trying to like
politicize this conversation right now
but i'm just saying it from a standpoint
of like if we look at the history and
the timeline look at when things started
to get more extreme because extremism is
is very present in all assets of like uh
pop culture mainstream media social
media right that's why we have guys like
andrew tate because the algorithm loves
it the algorithm loves extremism whether
it's extreme left or extreme right get
people to watch it yeah exactly they
don't care about how you feel they don't
care about what your reaction is they
but they know you're gonna get a
reaction and that's why it's suggested
to you and it's thrown in your face
people get riled up they're like
no i'm gonna [ __ ] say something you
know [ __ ] this guy right he doesn't even
care too because he lives in romania he
no it doesn't really you know him and
his [ __ ] brother
allegedly i guess i gotta say allegedly
they were running um
some sort of scam where webcam scam
where girls
like hot girls or whatever distressed
hot girls are getting guys to send them
money
they had a little ring of that [ __ ]
not to mention they also had uh police
raid their home because of uh reported
allegations of sex trafficking yeah
house or like yeah human trafficking or
an american girl american citizen girl
being held there against their will
and then you know no charges ended up
being filed and he was just saying these
are all lies to just attack me you know
these liberals or whatever
they don't uh they can't deal with the
fact that i'm i'm such an alpha male i'm
so good looking so have you seen a video
of this guy walking dude
you want to talk about a non-alpha male
walk yeah look at this full just look up
any clip of him walking it's the most
hilarious thing you'll ever see in your
life i had no [ __ ] idea who this dude
was before you mentioned him i i've
never seen him before i've never heard
him before like i was like he won't stop
popping up on my [ __ ] i don't understand
like why he and i well i do now yeah i
understand why yeah so it doesn't matter
because i would block all these channels
block block block block
but every time that channel will be
blocked there will be another channel
with it yeah and it's because of his
hustlers whatever what are the customers
universities university it's the way
they attack youtube they did it i'll say
this though
a lot of people say things are genius
right they take they say kim
kardashian's jeans because she sucked a
dick and she you know blew up no this is
an actual level of evil genius yeah he
got people to spread his gospel
willingly yeah through his pyramid
scheme and to the point where you can't
help but see him and that's [ __ ]
insane and it really goes to show too
especially on the social media platform
how everybody has their own niche
audience yeah and
if you can really just invoke a lot of
i don't know let's say
a lot of uh
not energy what's the word i'm looking
for a lot of confidence confidence
invoke a lot of confidence into your
followers they will do absolutely
anything for you
and they believe all the stuff that he's
saying like his definitive definition of
what a man is is
you know it's
what when people say toxic this is what
they're talking about no yeah that is
the prime example of toxic masculinity
and he just reminds me of a guy remember
like that show on mtv back in the day
the pickup artist oh yes where you like
neg women and do these certain things to
like get them
to pick up artists on this channel
yeah
i just imagine a guy like that
times 10. you know he's just like that
um
here's here's my biggest problem with
this too is that
listen if he's doing this for money and
views and looks that's fine right but
it's the same problem that i have with
other influencers who don't look at the
negative repercussions of what they do
right and i'm i fall in this category
too i'm a because i'm a comic by trade i
say a lot of stupid [ __ ] and you know
it's all comedy however
the issue that i have with influencers
like him is because he's trying to
create a crusade for something that he's
saying is important for the betterment
of mankind right right so there is this
whole in his view a certain uh sense of
morality in it which for me is a false
sense of morale yeah right the way that
he talks about women specifically how he
thinks that he could just own them and
with their property
it's
and i'm not just i'm talking about
literally i saw a video clip of him
because obviously they're all over the
place
of him just explaining why he wouldn't
allow a woman to go out to a club or
hang out with her girlfriend she's like
why unless you're the only sole purpose
of like i provide for her i give her
money i give her everything else i feed
her i put a roof over her head what
purpose does she have to go out with her
homegirls outside and go out and impress
other men to why simply just because she
wants to [ __ ] them and i won't allow my
woman to do that yeah i'm like allow
yeah exactly
she's probably of the mindset she
belongs in the kitchen yeah that's where
she should be too that means you're a
[ __ ] loser like you're you're the guy
that for some reason you feel that
you're so small that you need to control
your girl yeah because why because you
give her things yeah or maybe you're a
[ __ ] loser and the only thing that
you actually have to offer is money so
yeah you should be scared when they go
outside because you have nothing to
offer them because you're a [ __ ]
loser yeah
nobody would first of all i even hate
the way that he talks he's [ __ ] his
lips are all
you know
you look like a [ __ ] guppy bro shut
the [ __ ] up and i think like his main
thing the reason why a lot of guys see
him as an alpha male is because he
kickboxed for a living yeah yeah by the
way he wasn't even a dope kickboxer
right like the the the the level of
competition that he fought wasn't even
that dope and when he went to an actual
legitimate organization guess what
happened got knocked out so be quiet
yeah shut the [ __ ] up i mean his
audience has to be like
pre-pieces pre-pubescent teens to like
teenagers you know um boys who
aren't
yet too educated and and too mature and
and maybe you know they're they're in
parts of the the world or in the country
where um
you know it's
i had to think about this too it's why
is it that
when i read the comments from the people
who really do support andrew tate
whether it's for trolling purposes or
not i don't really know i'm just kind of
taking it for face value
it reminds me of these kids who are
who just have never been able to talk to
the opposite sex or
been able to talk to anybody that they
have a romantic interest in
and so what they do instead of looking
at themselves and saying oh maybe i'm a
little awkward maybe the way i approach
this girl is a little weird and i need
to kind of work on my game they go these
women don't like good men and they like
trash men and that's why i am not wanted
yeah so they take the blame and they put
it on the girl yeah they put it on the
woman as if it's their fault the reason
why they don't find them attractive as
if the attraction and the feelings are
owed to them so when somebody like
andrew tate says talks about oh putting
a woman in her place and being a high
value man using money that is the only
attribute that they can have in order to
attract these type of women that they
feel that they deserve so that's why
they really enjoy what andrew tate says
he's like oh it's not me it's because
these women don't know what a high level
man is and that's why these women need
to be put in their place because it
already prays to the feelings that they
already feel about women who have
rejected them and these are those incels
they enjoy that [ __ ] they see what they
want in themselves like oh this guy if
he knows how to get women and all he had
to do was get money i can do that yeah i
i'm i'm andrew tate yeah i'm a real
man's man and so i what i'm actually
doing and they think that it's a
positive thing as i'm fighting against
toxic feminine femininity yeah they
think that that's the crusade yeah i'm
fighting against toxic femininity so
these women who just don't know who
howard how to be a real woman let me
teach you what it is and i'll teach you
what it is to be a man
but it's it's
absolute nonsense yeah it's some
backwards-ass stupid [ __ ] and and look
it's turning
uh i hate it it turning insecurity into
confidence really right because all of
these in cells or or like uh aspiring in
cells right um they they feel insecure
about certain things like and then all
of a sudden they're like no it's not me
it's these women i'm a [ __ ] great guy
i have great qualities why would they
not like me because they're pieces of
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] that's why they're
horses yeah they they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they're no good and so i need to
teach them women women only want men who
are high value because of their money
and that's why they're [ __ ] it's like
well there are women like that and
there are also men like you yeah so
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
because i don't want to be associated
with men like you and i would also hate
it i hate to see if women relegated all
men to your type of behaviors so it
works both ways so what the [ __ ] are you
talking about it's just crazy in this
day and age where it's 2022 and you know
we have the technology and we have the
information out there for you to get
a pretty
let's say even um
even amount of information from from
both sides to come to like a a more
sensible conclusion and sense of it and
like get to the facts of things
but there's still this
[ __ ] old-school boomerass mentality
of like women or this
man or this
it's like my we're just human beings man
yeah we're human beings you know and i
get it too like i i believe to just grow
it up and obviously when you see it like
i think traditionally girls tend to have
certain tendencies and guys have that
and that's the stuff that comedians
always joke about yeah which has a
certain ring of truth to it but when it
comes to stuff like this this is just
absolute knowledge yeah yeah because
we're talking about things like equality
we're not we're thinking about uh we're
talking about things like human value
and they devalue women and and feel like
yeah women um
are just these helpless creatures that
need to be taught and and shown the way
they need they they feel like they need
to show the light to these to these
women these helpless
stupid horse
his horse
they know not their face
who who they will turn into an honest
woman by
keeping them in the kitchen and
preventing them from living a life i am
a warrior this whole has acne and
[ __ ] plaque all over his teeth
[ __ ] disgusting you know the crazy
[ __ ] is though you know who andrew tate
reminded me of when i was like looking
into it who he's a world famous painter
an artist who's the first name that
comes to mind when you think of just all
time like one of the great painters
david cho
i mean
he's you know he's a legend in his own
right but i'm saying like
okay well who else
um
[ __ ] man that uh
uh damn picasso there you go pablo
picasso is who it reminded me of and
you're probably thinking right now what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
right
so this is uh
you know again allegedly a little bit of
a dark side of pablo picasso but he was
definitely a womanizer at the very least
but there has been allegations and you
know stuff that's been said about him
that he's also
an abuser and a misogynist
and possibly even a rapist
yeah like
he's he's done some very questionable
things i mean he's dated a 17 year old
when he was 45 years old jesus christ
his his his reasoning was we're both in
our prime
in one world
i mean dude he was uh born like what i
think in the
1900s or something i mean he lived um
not that long ago he's like i have been
my wait is pop probably he was italian
yeah
no yeah yeah he's italian yeah he's
italian okay i was about to do a superb
he won 1981 he died in 1980 18 1881 and
he died in what like 1970 something was
it uh april 8
1973 1970 okay so he you know he was
around he was around damn this
[ __ ] lived hell along he he was
he was also a fascist um
but but let me let me read you something
that uh he has
allegedly said about women and that's
why i'm saying he
reminded me of um
this andrew tate guy
okay so he said
women are machines for suffering jesus
christ for me there are only two kinds
of women goddesses and doormats
every time i change wives i should burn
the last one that way i'd be rid of them
they wouldn't be around to complicate my
existence maybe that would bring back my
youth too you kill the woman and you
wipe out the past she represents
god
damn you wanna talk about
toxic masculinity
that was [ __ ] pablo picasso bro you
know this this [ __ ] world-renowned
respected artist one of the greats of
all time um that's [ __ ] crazy calling
women they're either doormats they are
goddesses a goddess or a doormat
well this is uh irrefutable but like his
muses and his mistresses or whatever in
the past um two of them have committed
suicide as a result of their
relationship with him
something like his even his own grandson
or some [ __ ] committed suicide but yeah
he was known to be a narcissist and and
like isn't it so sad that you have to be
a crazy person to create great art well
i mean it kind of comes with the
territory right you just have to be dude
it goes back to what we were talking
about right of like you don't ever know
who these people are but i feel like
when you're extremely talented it just
comes with the territory you're [ __ ]
cuckoo for coco puffs man this is why
i'll never make it in this industry man
i'm not at that level of crazy yet
and i feel like that's how you unlock
your genius yeah
dude he's such a great actor why no he
actually believes he's a character yeah
he's [ __ ] nuts
oh speaking of that um
somebody who's [ __ ] nuts guy like tom
cruise people look at him and think
right he's kind of did you know
christian bale
used him as an inspiration for
portraying patrick bates um in psycho
american psycho yeah he was inspiration
he saw um a late night interview with
tom cruise and he was looking at him
and his observation was like
dude this doesn't seem real this guy
seems like a guy trying to wear the mask
of a human and trying to act human
something feels very and christian
bale's kind of crazy to himself
so when a crazy person looks at you and
says
exactly it's like yo what the [ __ ] see
this is what i'm saying
i really do believe just because like
as time goes on we have to make
adjustments towards our education system
right
and early on you know before us and you
would see these in movies like in the
60s or the 50s or even the 70s where
they would have classes teaching
stuff that pertain to everyday life at
the time right so like homeek and all
this other [ __ ] right well now there
needs to be a course about how to teach
young kids how to socialize properly
because they're not getting that all
their socialization is through the
internet and typing things uh and not
seeing somebody face-to-face speaking so
they can build up this fake sense of
bravado because they don't have to be
faced with another human person they
don't have to see real life emotions and
have actual interactions with them yeah
so now there needs to be a course where
you have an actual educated person teach
them how to socialize
bro you have some very high hopes for
the american educational
let me tell you man i got a ticket to
heaven i could sell you are you
interested
i'll tell you this i think it's very
much [ __ ] needed i will be the
professor
and be like
i want to i want to do a course where i
have boys and girls yeah or guy and girl
whatever the [ __ ] your preference is and
i want to
simulate a date situation and then i'm
gonna sit there and coach them like a
guy's gonna sit down and be like you
order your food i'm like hey listen here
you [ __ ] dummy all right
talk to the person first don't start
doing this [ __ ] right listen here you
little [ __ ] what you gotta tell this
girl is that you wanna bury your face in
their face
what you gotta do is dm them and say
listen i want to suffocate in between
those cheeks for hours and hours
and if they giggle you're good if you're
not you're bad yeah no no if they don't
laugh at it then they're a [ __ ] yeah
just remember that have you heard of
this place called hustlers university
so i'm gonna tell you this funny-ass
story so there was a a friend of mine
she's been trying to go on these dates
through these dating apps and she has
had
strike after strike
that's like every girl's story bro
show me the profile of these dudes yeah
and
it's dry out there for these ladies
right well not only i mean dry and
there's just it's just horrible some of
this [ __ ] that i hear from my other
girlfriends of life dude i'm gonna tell
you this story yeah so she just went on
a date recently and then you know
talking on the phone
and she was telling me she was you could
share the story on the podcast if you
want because i want people to hear this
[ __ ]
so
off jump he goes
hey let's meet up let's for coffee on
our first date
that's fine he goes let's he's like i
want to meet you at porto's the worst
date spot ever first of all portal's on
a sunday so [ __ ] busy he's hella busy
lying out the door you can't hear [ __ ]
because everybody's so [ __ ] loud he
chooses [ __ ] portals number one think
about the location and where you're
going this is the first date you're
supposed to have a conversation and
get to know each other you [ __ ] dummy
and she was already kind of put off by
that she goes whatever i like the coffee
and [ __ ] so
instead of saying i'll meet you at the
front so they can introduce each other
he goes i will be in line just look for
me
are you a idiot are you [ __ ] dumb and
already is this going bad yeah you know
he's not putting his best foot forward
yeah look for me look for me [ __ ] what
is this
look for me
so
this is happening
she goes and meets him and i [ __ ] you
[ __ ] nut
he sits there they get their coffee he
drinks his she drinks hers
and he goes oh what did you get the
drink i got a lot to have like simple
drinks oh cool
what's he do next grabs her drink
and drinks from her drink no
[ __ ] no
covid yeah first of all yeah even if it
wasn't kovid yeah are you [ __ ] nuts
yeah who who [ __ ] does that so she's
watching this guy yeah in slow-mo yeah
take the drink put his [ __ ] dirty ass
lips on it yeah drink from it and puts
it back and she just goes did you just
drink from my drink yeah
is that like
and he goes oh uh he's korean by the way
and this is what i got so mad he goes oh
i'm from a korean family and we share
everything so i'm just used to that i'm
not okay first of all bro no
absolutely not no no
there's two korean people here yeah
there's no [ __ ] korean person on the
very first date the person you just met
where you grab their drink without even
asking them put your filthy little mouth
on it and then give it back and be like
you just i've never [ __ ] taken like
my mom or dad or my sister said let hold
up real quick and he put it on the
culture it goes oh yeah no that's the
korean thing no
it's not no that's a dumbass thing is
what that is it is not a korean thing at
all yeah that [ __ ] made me so mad he
takes that stuff for the rest of the
date he just starts grilling her with
questions
constantly and she starts talking about
himself for like 10 or 15 minutes yeah
and she had enough and then she was like
okay we're done and then started walking
goes oh
no social awareness at all by this point
because i had a really great time
so when are we going to do our second
date
he was like i would like to see you
again is that okay she goes no no
she walks into the car and just drives
off so
she's home she's telling us this stuff i
can't believe the type of the social iq
is so [ __ ] low yeah it blows my mind
that's i hear time and time again like i
said from my girlfriends with their bad
experiences bro there's people guys who
right off the bat maybe like second
third message in they will send them a
dick pic holy [ __ ] yeah it happens it's
it's a lot more common than you think i
would argue that any girl who's used
like you know these apps or whatever
have probably gotten a dick pic at some
point you know for me a hundred percent
you send me a [ __ ] dick pic that's
going to your mom
if i was a girl
or if i was a gay yeah
i would be like listen i'm saying this
to your mom bro yeah done how dare you
but speaking of of your friend that's
why you always do a coffee date because
the exit's a lot easier yeah then like
it did smart move yeah then like i
remember i was talking to this girl
and she was telling cause she said she
absolutely hates coffee dates and i was
just wanting to you know i didn't
suggest the coffee date i was just she
just said that right juice
so i i was just curious i was like you
know what what is it that makes you feel
so
negative about a coffee date it's like
because it's so boring and it's so
stupid i was like okay so what's the
alternative then are you always looking
to do like some sort of um left field
like uh fun exciting uh random types of
dates it's like no just a nice dinner
date and i'm like well what's really the
difference within a dinner date because
he's going to pay for it well so so
basically she was like well then i get
to observe his behavior and see his
etiquette how he treats the waiter and
if the date is bad i know at the end of
the night i still get a nice meal i'm
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] i was like yeah
yeah and i was like i was like okay so
if a coffee date is stupid and boring
then what if you know the the dinner
date ends up being stupid and boring as
well right and she's like well like i
said then i just get a nice meal out of
it i was like oh so you're expecting the
guy to automatically pay not only pay
for your dinner which is fine you know
like if somebody decides to pay whether
it's a guy or girl you go half these
whatever but you expect to be taken to a
nice place too
and then she's like yeah of course
and i'm like well
i mean
what what do you like how do you think
this works right and she's like well you
know i i should get treated to a nice
dinner at the very least if i'm gonna
give you my time and she's like because
i don't have time i don't got time to
waste like that and i'm like okay so you
don't have time to waste like that and
that at this point just started trolling
her you know she just started coming
him be like do you think you have a nice
dinner date [ __ ] yeah
no no i don't think so i was like okay
so you don't have enough time to meet
with people yet you say coffee dates are
stupid and boring but you have enough
time to meet for a full dinner date even
if it goes it makes no sense i was like
that makes absolutely no sense and i
started flipping her logic on her and
then she started getting defensive and i
was like oh my god you are so stupid
i mean this is really like
well it's the idea that i mean for her
how i feel about that is like
you expect this guy to entertain you no
yes you're pretentious it's very very
pretentious yeah like
so i could [ __ ] like monitor him and
see his behavior there's the reason why
i dislike that it's like
i believe somebody like that what she is
forgetting is like you know when that
guy is also on that date he's not trying
to figure out if
uh he's good for you he's trying to
figure out if you're good for him as
well yeah exactly
both ways yeah so the idea that you feel
like well he has to entertain me he
needs to pay for this yeah he needs to
impress me he needs to show me his value
it's like you also need to show him your
value yeah and my idea is too is like
listen
because
i'm traditional i will pay for the meal
right 100 that's not a problem but who's
to say to the date goes well he just
looks like he probably goes nah i'm good
and walks away yeah so how does that
work out then right right
that's just a really odd thing like the
reason why the coffee date makes sense
is because number one the x is good and
also there's no expectations it's a lot
more casual so if you really want to see
who somebody is then you do the coffee
that's what i'm saying but she was
looking at this like you know you better
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah for me yeah
exactly like you better come with that
super proper etiquette and and like
grade a everything take me to a nice
fancy dinner pay for it treat me
entertain like legit if yeah if i felt
this woman was grading me as a human
being number one it's very degrading i
probably would just stop to dinner and
be like you know what okay no see that's
the thing guys like me and you are
people like me and you we got no problem
being [ __ ] raw dog and just in the
middle of something like that we're good
but the i'm saying for the average
person it can be very uncomfortable in
like a formal dinner setting right i've
literally
bro i literally broke up with a girl
yeah who flew out of state cave here not
broken we were dating to visit me
because of the way she spoke to me like
did i tell you the story this story is
[ __ ] funny
we're about to wrap this up but
i got a text from a girl who has the
same name as a homegirl right and i
didn't have both of their numbers
is this another one of this wrong
message so
i get a text from this girl and she
texts me let's call her jennifer
jennifer texted me and i go oh what's up
you go i'm gonna be in town like you
want to meet up i don't have a place to
crash one crash at your place
that means she wants to hook up however
in my mind i thought this was the old
friend so i was like of course dude yeah
like come over whenever yeah it's like
yeah we haven't i haven't seen you in so
long and what i meant by so long was
like
three four years yeah what she was
talking about is i haven't seen her like
in a month because we were kind of
lightweight dating yeah and i i for some
reason
not dating but we were talking to each
other but for some reason i confused
those two people up
and so i [ __ ] you i know this sounds so
[ __ ] unbelievable but she flies
from out of state comes to the door and
i see her yeah this other other jennifer
i was expecting another one and i didn't
put two and two together yeah as he goes
hey and i'm like what are you doing here
she's like joking around she comes in
and i'm like no seriously what are you
doing here yeah and she's like
we just talked i told you that i was i
was coming over i needed a place to
crash and i'm like
yeah i knew that oh it hit me in my head
as the wheels were turning and i go holy
[ __ ] this isn't jennifer kim yeah this
is the other jennifer kim yeah i was
flabbergasted but either way it was fine
she comes over and we're kicking in my
and mind you the only time i really
kicked it with her or we like made out
was when she was visiting on these short
spurts so
we never really established a hardcore
really especially for her to stay over
yeah yeah i know i would have never had
a casual dating relationship type of
thing i would have never done that so
she comes over and in like day two we
start we had this simple conversation
and it was a disagreement about
something right and she snaps at me and
she curses at me oh and in the middle of
it i look at her
and i stop and i go
hey this isn't going to work out yeah
her response till this day made me we
still we're still friends yeah
had me dying laughing because i go hey
this is not going to work out she goes
why
oh my god after she just started cursing
it cursing me out yeah why
her demeanor changed the immediate
immediately and i go here's the reason
why i think we're really cool
but
this wasn't even argument worthy this is
like in our honeymoon stage where we're
dating and you already cursed at me yeah
and you spoke to me in a super
disrespectful manner if this is where we
start it's not going to end very well
especially with my personality
i would i don't stand for that stuff
because i would never speak to you that
way no matter how angry i am yeah and
you went from zero to a thousand
immediately we only been around each
other for two days yeah absolutely why
remember that story i told you about
like that girl who had come over to my
place she wanted to hook up like uh it
was it was that night dave uh david troy
got into it oh yeah yeah you remember
that girl remember that story oh my god
kind of like that guys the same [ __ ]
dude that's just so [ __ ] funny man
well guys we could we could talk for
hours but we got to wrap this up uh
real quick
uh remember
we're gonna drop a genius brain secret
society collab i know i've been talking
about this podcast it's it's coming doc
it's [ __ ]
i'm so happy with this [ __ ] it's unreal
yeah um yeah
i was saying look objectively even if i
wasn't involved i would look at it and
be like that should stop as [ __ ] you
know so
i can't wait for for the people to
finally see it um and
we're gonna have information about it
shortly i believe today might be when we
see the final rounds of the sample so
if that is the case then we'll have
pre-orders open up hopefully even within
the week i mean we'll have to see but
yeah yeah um it's just
dave knows this but the process has been
a little more complicated of just
because of how intricate the design is
and all the little details in it so
we've been trying to get it just right
the colors uh yeah the lines and
everything and and that's been proving
to be a little bit more difficult than
we had initially thought but again we
want to get that just
100 well guys
get ready for that you could see our
edrick at
ed2 on instagram check out secret
society s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y
genius brain every sunday's at 12 p.m
and we'll see you all next time alright
peace
[Music]